so you may have seen this video an
Amazon delivery driver in Apple Valley
California dropping off packages when he
steps and falls inside a septic tank it
happened last week while he was stuck
the driver uploaded this video
it's so delivering to this customer's
house and I just fell into a septic tank
I think it I don't know if they were
digging it or what but I walked by it
and the ground came out underneath me
I'm like six feet down and I tried using
these roots around me to get out and it
just pulled more dirt on top of me so I
just called dispatch hopefully they're
going to get the cops or the fire
department here because I definitely
don't want to try to climb out on my own
again because like I said the walls are
kind of caving in on me a little bit
scary
so the fire department did come and
rescue that man and here's the thing at
a moment when people are dismissing
American workers as lazy or disengaged
that man took a shower and then
continued his route and we were very
impressed with that in fact we gave him
the employee of the month honors and
then we found him his name is Charles
and mcangelo he joins us tonight trust
I'm so impressed with this thank you for
joining us
um thank you you fell into this like a
tiger trap without seeing it is that
correct
um no actually I did see the hole um I
walked by it uh on my way to deliver a
package and then I walked by it again on
my way back to my vehicle and uh the
ground next to the hole is what
collapsed underneath me uh even though I
I kept a bit of a distance from the hole
I still managed to fall in because of
the ground collapsing under my feet and
uh also I wanted to let you know the
fire department confirmed with me the
drop wasn't six feet it was actually 13
feet
that's unbelievable
um so I mean I'm sure you see all kinds
of things on your route every day I mean
it you know famously a pretty
interesting job weird people dogs
um have you ever fallen into a deep hole
before
this is not something I would have ever
imagined happened no Tucker and I don't
think other delivery drivers would have
either
your your coolness Under Pressure
inspires the rest of us but also your
commitment to your job I mean once you
fall into a 13-foot septic hole I mean
you kind of deserve the day off I mean
people take holidays off I've never
heard of before did you consider just
calling it a day and having a beer
I did consider it
um you know I think um there was there
was several things that that caused me
to decide to go ahead and finish the
route and you know it was probably I was
on a good Adrenaline Rush
um you know my time in the Marine Corps
you know as a marine you know we're
conditioned to always accomplish our
mission you know so that was going
through my head but another big thing is
that um had I not uh completed my route
or attempted to at least other drivers
who had already been out there and done
their entire routes would would get
stuck having to finish my route and I
just didn't think that would be fair to
them either but I did voluntarily offer
to take my route so I hope you're
rewarded for it you certainly have our
admiration for it Charleston mckangelo
thank you for joining us tonight thank
you Tucker so impressive subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight